so I think that what's unique on in in
in what I'm doing or what we're doing is
that we are building a
product that our friends and family uses
okay so whenever we do a good job so my
mom tells me wow this is was amazing
this feature was very very cool and if
and if we do a shitty job so my friends
tell me listen your your trading
platform doesn't help me so you have you
have a you have a huge uh aspir to win
you want to do it right okay we are all
customers of our own product which is
amazing you can't say it on any other
product but when you build what we build
so everybody is affected so this is why
we are so uh Enthusiast about
[Music]
this he alne welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for joining me
thank you for having me m thanks really
really excited to be here with you quite
ironically we're in two different rooms
of the one zero
offices and uh very very happy to be
talking at such a pivotal time um not
just for AI not just for the world the
crazy world that we're living in but but
the way that this emerging landscape of
of gen and consumer behavior is Shifting
the digital banking space you know
oftentimes banking is thought of as one
of those you know really old and
classical institutionalized
industries that is very slow to adapt
yet what we're seeing with one zero for
example and you know in just first
months of 2024 it's it's quite
incredible to me um as a technologist
and entrepreneur to see a a bank you
know adopt really cutting edge and
leading Technologies you know pretty
much right as they're coming out and as
they're becoming um a part of our daily
lives and so I'm really curious to hear
about about what's happening here before
we do that take me a little bit into
your own journey and how you became an
executive here at at one Z and a little
bit about what what you're thinking
about in the day today yeah perfect um
so I'm Al GNE I'm 38 I live in Tel Aviv
I have two kids um after spending some
time in the Army I was uh I was working
as a as a strategic advisor uh for PWC
then I had a startup a fintech startup
we did expense management for small
medum
businesses um then I was part of of the
of the initial team that built this the
the business plan of what was called
first digital bank here in Israel and is
now known as one zero uh this was four
and a half years ago I've been always
working on the on the on both parts of
tech and finance I have a uh first
degree in accounting and law and I have
a master degree MBA in
finance um I love Tech very much I think
that these two worlds combined together
can really change the way that we
experience most of our of our
interactions in life uh surrounding
Finance um so four and a half years ago
we started by building a business plan
trying to see if there's a if there's a
way to get a banking license here in
Israel we actually succeeded and then in
the beginning of 2020 uh we started to
build a bank so started from a pure
technological uh uh project of building
a tech platform on top of a local core
system then it became some kind of uh of
an organizational project building a
bank uh recruiting 400
employees uh building like dozens of
financial products in the bank uh all
the procedures everything that you can
think
of and I think that more than everything
trying to build something which is new
okay not not just any other bank not
just something that you know from your
old bank but a different way that we
thought uh uh people need to experience
Finance so I think from day one uh a lot
thanks to Professor Amon shashua uh the
main shareholder and and and and uh the
one who actually started all this we
were very keen on finding um a
differentiating factor what will be
interesting in terms of building a new
digital bank because there are 300 or
500 digital banks in the world so it's
not really interesting just being
another one I think that instead of that
what what Professor shashua tried to
understand from the beginning is can we
actually change something uh
significantly can we actually
have a um a huge impact on on the world
okay on the world of Finance in in in
this specific example so just like any
other company that he has uh Mobil
obviously which a lot of of of guys know
it's all about trying to understand how
Ai and how technology can change the way
that that that you that you I don't know
um consume a product uh get service or
anything like that we understood that
the real issue here in banking or in
finance is that nobody knows how to
manage Finance really I told you I have
an MBA in in in finance I'm supposed to
be pretty good in managing Finance but
actually most of the people don't know
how to do it don't want to do it or
don't have the time to do it so we're
actually trying to think what if
technology can can do it for them okay
what if we can actually build a bank
which is not a self-service app that
gives you pie charts and and and some
some bar charts which is not interesting
but instead gives you advice show you
Financial forecast and actually help you
decide uh on on on how to manage all of
your finances starting from current
accounts going through deposits and
loans and and all the way until your
long-term savings as pension and
portfolio uh of
Securities and what is it that gen is
now unlocking in order to reach that
that sort of vision of not just being
the the the money holder and the
transaction executioner but also the the
guide and the the figure that can
actually support consumers and their
ability to manage their finances yeah so
so so I think that when you start asking
people if if they love or hate of or or
hate their Banks so most of them will
say that they hate their Banks but if
you ask them if they love or hate their
Bankers they will say no no I love my
banker okay she knows me from from from
when I was 16 or he knows me for five
years so that the actual interaction is
amazing the only problem is with the the
the whole experience right so J actually
gives you the the the option
to just uh imitate the the the free chat
if just the one that you would have if
you sit across your Banker in a in a in
a branch and you can ask him anything
and it can gives you a a uh I don't know
well educated answers and not just
choosing from a decision Tree in a chat
bot okay so I think that this this
basically changes everything because now
when customers uh uh have access or or
Banks and businesses like ours has
access to to to Cutting Edge
Technologies of of of geni so we can
actually provide an experience that you
would like to have and you don't feel
like someone is saving costs on your
back you don't feel like someone says
okay I'm busy and I want to fire my my
my employees so take this app and manage
it it's it's it's completely different
because you would get the right answer
you would get it immediately you don't
have to to wait to anybody and you can
ask as much or or as many follow-up
questions as you would like on any on
any domain or or area uh uh that
interests you MH and so paint me paint
me sort of this vision of yours for what
what banking could be in terms of the
consumer Behavior so I I understand the
you know the the incredible leap that
we're making in in the fact that your
bank you don't not only you know you
take the banker Persona and the relation
the the positive relationship you have
with that now you implemented into the
the actual the actual banking I guess
infrastructure what is that how is that
going to impact me as a consumer in my
day-to-day with my bank how do you
envision those flows so let's try to
understand that there are two different
paths that that we are working or or or
that anybody else who would like to
solve it uh needs to work in one would
be to actually have uh good data on you
clean it make sure
you you can use it uh and then use
Financial forecasting tools which are
obviously machine learning and AI Bas
based uh in order to actually try to
forecast what will happen with your
finances tomorrow in 30 days time next
year in 20 years okay midterm shortterm
longterm everything and then if if I
actually know it uh uh and if I can if I
can actually utilize data on on a
customer or using Market data as well
enriching everything with macroeconomic
uh data obviously and if and and if if I
actually know it so now the Second
Challenge or or the second path is is
the way to communicated with the
customer okay so the experience that
that that that the customer will have is
like he he has the the smartest CFO in
the world just sitting here on his
shoulder
giving him an amazing Financial advice
he can he can tell him listen you have
spare cash flow in your account why won
you uh put it in a in this very smart
saving plan okay it's risk-free I know
that you that you're going to need the
money in one year time don't take any
unnecessary risks let's do it in the in
the savings account or you can tell him
listen I know that you want to save for
retirement that means that we can have a
very very Diversified portfolio longterm
uh uh looking now most of us we don't
have access to this type of advice okay
uh most of of of uh of the affluent Mass
affluent and mass Market customers don't
have it at best case they can they can
call their smart friend okay who goes to
to to to Stanford or or or Harvard or or
or whatever but most of us don't have it
so if you actually have this smart Bank
okay who can use all the data
forecast everything and interact with
you when it suits you it can be in 2 am.
it can be on on on Saturday night it's
not when the bank is open okay so it's
actually a very different experience and
if I as as a customer can just get into
the App log in very very uh quickly and
then just ask any question that I would
like using a free text chat platform so
this is a different uh experience of of
of not only banking but any Financial
Service that you can think of what I
think is I you know immediately when you
said about the financial advice I was
thinking back to all the all the
financial experts and all the podcasts
and what is the first sentence they're
saying this is not Financial advice
don't call this accountable but and I
think that's it's it's an important note
here because there this is financial
advice and um and so what is the
complexity or the additional complexity
where we're now you know we're looking
at geni some of the things you know
there is talks about hallucinations and
different and different you know biases
that these models have and sometimes you
know Chad GPT has a huge warning
disclaimer you know don't trust
necessarily the information H you know
literally today we're February 22nd the
time of filming Google took a you know
paused their work with their image
generator because of a lack of coherence
in the results how do you now
strategically position the you know this
the ability to to take this amazing
technology to generate Financial advice
with the complexities that it brings
with it yeah so I'll give you two uh
different answers and both of them are
obviously and both of them are are are
legit so one you can just tell to to a
customer that there is a probability of
mistake it's all a matter of how how
much risk you are willing to take so I
can even do it uh um
um differently for for any type of
customer according to the risk profile
right so if a customer hates risk I will
hedge the the the model as much as I can
and he would only get answers on
specific things if a customer is is is
uh is a risk AV verion is is much higher
maybe I can tell him listen this is the
advice you're getting um some of it
should be double checked but so so so
this is one one easy way to to manage it
the more complex way to manage it and
this is what we do for instance is to
use um first of all we are using two
different Services of of GPT we we use
cat GPT in order to enhance uh or or or
to enrich the the the language or or the
Waring of of our answers we are also
using AI 21 Labs uh uh amazing service
obviously uh and their models have a
better way to manage or or to to avoid
eluc
so in the finance industry this is
amazing okay because accuracy is a thing
so we use a21 Labs it helps us a lot we
do a lot of the calculations internally
in our data warehouses but only and and
and and try to use this model just to
enrich the language the experience the
the back and forth
conversation in incredible so a little
bit back to to sort of your background
and your excitement here because I'm I'm
getting you know from just from these
last 14 minutes I'm I'm getting the
excitement and the energy that that you
have you know how what does this mean to
you you know building these Technologies
you know lead helping lead an
organization that can lead this
transformation how how do you see your
role here yeah so I think that what's
unique on in in in what I'm doing or
what we're doing is that we are building
a
product that our friends and family uses
okay so whenever we do a good job so my
mom tells me wow this was amazing this
feature was very very cool and if and if
we do a shitty job so my friends tell me
listen your your trading platform
doesn't help me so you have you have a
you have a huge uh aspiration to win you
want to do it right okay we are all
customers of our own product which is
amazing you can't say it on any other
product but when you build what we build
so everybody is affected so this is why
we are so uh in iast about this
personally I've been doing a lot of
roles in in one zero starting from from
uh uh um being the the COO then then uh
managing the product then the finance
and soon after we do some some
separation of of our companies because
we have a bank we have a tech company
I'll I'll I'll be leading the bank the
the Israel Bank itself so it's very
exciting for me as well because um if
you have the passion for it if you are
willing to put on the to put in the the
hard work and if you want to make things
happen and and and and you have the the
I would I would say uh
um um aspiration or or or experience uh
uh like I had here so this is very
exciting and and when was it that you
were doing your MBA in finance remind me
um don't remember I think uh five years
ago something like that so even five
years ago so 2019 did you you know think
back to how you were looking at the
space and you're looking at from a
business perspective did you have any
anticipation that five years later you
would be working on pioneering
completely new consumer behavior when it
comes to
finances um not like this five years ago
I would think that I I don't know I'll
try to use machine learning to do
valuations of companies or stuff or
stuff like that I think that getting
into building something like uh private
digital banking like like we're trying
to do is is is really amazing as as an
opportunity and um I told you before the
the where where finance and Tech Ms I
think this is super exciting and I like
it a lot and and you know incredibly and
I think that way you touched on earlier
in the conversation where there is a
fundamental pain point that people don't
know what to do with their finances
whether because they don't know or
because they don't want to
and that that is really solving a core
problem and we have we have full
startups that provide this service
except they don't have access right the
way that you do they don't have the the
understanding necessarily and the and
the fundamental uh roots in in the
industry take me three four years down
the line I mean obviously things are
changing so fast and if we're looking at
if you know this is where we're headed
you know what is you know few years from
now really the future of banking for you
well I can't uh uh guarantee it's it's
it's three or four years but I think
that that the world is going through to
uh embedded Finance I think that it's
it's pretty obvious when you look on all
the solutions all the tech Solutions
around us uh your refrigerator is smart
your car is super smart your bank can
be a genius right when all of these
things are are are interconnected
together I think that the experience
that we as as consumers will have is
something that that it's very hard for
us to to to to imagine but we will drive
our cars something will will be I don't
know uh broken down the car will know it
the car will access my bank account
we'll make sure how much money I have to
repair it we'll contact the the the the
autoshop everything will happen while
the car is driving me to to to work so
we as human beings can be super
efficient you know we'll do what we want
to do or what we need to do but not what
we don't want to do and hopefully we
will be saved from doing something we
shouldn't do ER like impulse buying or
buying something that we can't actually
pay for down the line right yeah I can
only imagine the forecast the the
incredible forecasting that will happen
even when it comes to how it relates to
your job and and potential you know
Market effect here um let me just one
more thing about this because I have a
very cool example of of something that
we have been doing in in the last couple
of months
so given so so our Tech helps our
Bankers to uh to avoid doing technical
stuff okay if the machine is is is doing
some of the works for them so they
actually have time to do what we call
value added uh tasks okay um during the
last couple of months in Israel we knew
that some of the customers would
appreciate a
call we have Bankers they were free
because the machine is doing the heavy
lifting they just called customers from
the south of is of Israel just to check
up on them the the the the effect was
was amazing okay so even if if you think
on how our jobs will change we will
actually be able to do more value added
tasks you know human touch which makes a
difference and not just technical stuff
incredible a thank you so much for the
time um February 2024 I can only imagine
looking back at this a year from now or
even less and and seeing what happens
and where the space is evolving but
thank you so much for sharing this time
with me I really appreciate it my
pleasure thank you
[Music]